[Music]
[Applause]
the narrative and style and food text
creation on social media and when I talk
about the food text I mean I got an
image a recipe a blog it started with
like my catch-all term for media that's
created to talk about - there we go so
what is the future of society in food a
lot of things we think about the
sustainability the nutrition the
economics and access points that come
into the debate when talking about food
today and these are very very important
parts of food culture and they need to
be addressed however if we want any of
the interventions that companies and
industries and people are creating to
catch on we need to think about what are
their barriers of adoption and more
broadly than price point and supply
chain like how will this actually become
something that people will use and so
that is kind of a piece of the puzzle
that innovation companies typically
don't think about they just think about
this can save world hunger but they
don't think about how do I actually get
people to eat it and want to eat it so
with that in mind I originally had
started my my research by thinking about
this idea of why are people afraid of
new technological foods for example like
cricket powders which isn't really that
new but in terms
like a western market it's a new thing
that people are thinking of and so I
spoke with mark post who's a scientist
in the Netherlands and he was the
founder of lab gurney our in vitro meat
I don't know if you've seen the petri
dishes with the burger inside he's the
one who who started that so the first
lab ground burger was made in 2013 and
it cost about two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to produce at the time
but today in 2018 they're able to make
it at ten dollars so that is scaled down
and so talking to him I wasn't asking
him about the science I was kind of
asking him like what are the
communication problems you've
encountered with with kind of creating
this product and he would say look we
have all the technology we need to solve
world hunger we have all the technology
to move away from an animal-based diet
you can have protein supplements very
readily available it's the cultural
issue that comes into place so he said
there's something more of food than the
issues of sustainability or nutrients it
is about the rule the role food has
within our society and the rituals that
are built around it it is the context
and stories around foods that lead us to
keep on eating them think of the rituals
of like a barbecue and health drawn to
us how drawn we are to like the smells
of umami and grilling meat so
so if we want to produce new food
inventions we need to figure out how to
make them fit within our stories and the
cultures we live in and so with that in
mind while all the components of a fully
functioning food system cannot be
minimized
I want to uncover how visual images of
food are used as tools for communication
and community building specifically what
role do the digital platforms and Inter
information communication tools have in
this changing relationship we have to
our food
so in particular I looked at digitally
circulated media artifacts in a Western
context that featured food as a primary
subject and like I said I'll call these
food text frequently and also like why
media well I'm gonna this is the only
theory I'm gonna drop so enjoy
sociologist Erving Goffman contended in
his book the presentation of self in
everyday life that each person within a
social interaction is attempting to
guide and control impressions that are
farms about themselves so likewise
interpreting social data about others
are key parts of survival within social
interaction this is important to be able
to anticipate the outcome or the end
product of an activity as well as the
other person's feelings towards
themselves and so while we don't have
full data available to us about another
person their intentions and their true
feelings people typically infer these
aspects by social interactions using
clues such as hints expressive gen
gestures cues or static symbols that is
to say without knowing someone in Foley
we draw impressions based on
interpreting the outward appearances and
what they do
so therefore content created and
circulated via social media typically
gets interpreted as these clues
we use to understand each other and
figure out our relationships to them so
for my methods
I had interviews and visits with chefs
food industry professionals media makers
I surveyed a lot of people who liked and
disliked food social media content I did
a survey with over a hundred social
media users and 98% of them had
encountered food-related content so it's
pretty it's a safe bet to call you both
it is at this point in our social media
landscape I did a primary source review
of lots of different types of food texts
in particular I looked at archival
magazine documents Instagram posts
Twitter tweets blog post forums and lots
lots more and I did a survey on existing
research on food and media trends and
this food studies is kind of this
burgeoning field that exists across so
many different disciplines so I looked
at what there wasn't Media Studies but
also history anthropology computer
science even psychology and sociology so
all these things come together to
illustrate the convergences so how
they're similar in divergences how
they're different in the creation and
consumption of who texts throughout time
so what did I find out well food is
definitely a vessel for communication
and this we've known for a really long
time but now with these digital channels
their communication potential has been
amplified and it's the affordances of
digital media in particular the
widespread networks that travels through
that helps give them more social
importance to the messages people use to
communicate with each other so this
gives food a new platform for
communication but also the power dynamic
of food types creation has shifted from
primarily originating from the expert to
now mainly coming from mainstream diners
or social media connected food so how
did we get here
[Music]
and so now you see why this presentation
comes after lunch so what do I mean like
how did we get here what is here in this
particular case this is the intro
whatever it's was like the intro scene
to the second season of chefs table on
Netflix and in this particular case
there is an artistic treatment of the
footage documenting the process of
creation of the fine dining experience
in the creation of the food the creation
of the space and just the whole story
that's being told and both elements such
as the ingredients on the tables and the
people who cook the food and the kitchen
cooks and you saw the the faces of the
chef's very melodramatically composed
and showed its its really saying that
the food we're eating is not just for
utility anymore there's there's much
more depth to this process and it's
being treated with with a lot of respect
and this is new but not so many so the
story that I that I'm gonna unfold for
you right now is exemplary
not exhaustive so what I mean by that is
I'm showing specific moments and pieces
of what I think represent a larger turn
in the rough time and so let's start in
the mid 20th century right around World
War Two so Gourmet magazine the magazine
of good living
it has agenda of expanding cultural
horizons through culinary exploring
explorations since its first printing in
1941 in the mid 20th century there was
the mass importation of European foods
and flavors and an increasing ease of
Atlantic travel which positions food is
a dynamic part of social and cultural
explorations and now the key word there
is explorations in particular gourmet
was pointed to as an indicator of how
Americans had dropped their puritanical
mentalities around food and the sense
that it was just simply a utility in
favor of an opportunity to exercise the
tastebuds with a variety of interesting
flavors and to enjoy the experience in
the company of family and friends so
this is kind of where gourmet food
culture started being filmed and and so
there's this reflexive relationship
between recipe execution in a domestic
space and the socio-cultural connections
that emerge from dining out and travel
however these connections have existed
within food culture at different lengths
at one another in particular the rise of
food and lifestyle magazines in the mid
20th century paralleled growing consumer
interest and exploring how new social
and cultural avenues of food could could
be experienced through the comfort of
home and so this is the direction
because a lot of things we like to think
about food porn and this sort of modern
phenomenon but this is a photo from 1844
then you could probably put on the
screen maybe with a little bit different
and now we see a lot of people doing
food arrangement and this is what I'm
saying this isn't new just the ways we
experience it are new
so now we're going to speed up in it and
look at food text through time now we're
in the mid 90s to the early aughts and
more recently in the tail end of the
20th century in the beginning of the
21st century digital avenues allowed for
these cross cultural and community
connections to flourish with ease and at
increasing speeds while the experience
of cooking for oneself in one's home was
once private the Joel Media expanded the
public purview of home cooking in an
unlikely in from fowl away cooking at
home became not only a cultural
experience but also a social experience
and just to give you some some dates to
keep in mind Food Network was launched
in 1993 and one more main stream in 1997
but that's where we're looking at kind
of coming on TV in a very widespread
network way and the first recipe website
was Epicurious and it came out in 1995
from honey nest and what's super
interesting about Epicurious is they
were one of their first few digital
publications that was digital first they
it wasn't a magazine that was trying to
figure out how to beat digital it's
totally started digital and it's a
pretty cool story so I came the idea
came from Rachelle udel who was an
editor at Conde Nast and she had an
experience on an AOL chat where it was
the night before Thanksgiving and people
were helping each other figure out how
to cook their turkeys and she was like
this is amazing that I can have all
these people helping me in my kitchen
being digitally connected so they ended
up taking all the recipes from Conde
Nast and print and licensing them and
they had to get all thousands and
thousands of recipes digitized to put it
on the web
and this was before OCR anything like
that so they actually sent it to a
digital month firm that these monks in
Virginia would transcribe all the
recipes
and apparently this was like a super
common practice in the beginning of the
internet is these digital monks like
built the internet and that's pretty
cool so that's a pull like hidden labor
thing thinking back to some of the other
presentations they were getting cleaned
up min so by 1998 Epicurious had a
recipe database of 76 hundred recipes
and by 2005 they had twenty thousand
recipes and they expand they were one of
the first groups to be on YouTube so
that was pretty cool I gots have seen
those videos of their hands making food
from must be tasty
well Epicurious did that way before like
in the early 2000s on youtube and they
had crossovers with williams-sonoma to
advertise on their site they had a
Discovery Channel series based on their
show and this was like I said all based
on on this online site and this is the
site map of the first thing and some of
the
whole pages so they kind of replicate
what are these papers look like at first
but they could do really interactive
things like make maps of growing speeds
in and that was really basic thing we've
been the first person and so in my story
also I wanted to bring in the voices of
some some people and I had the pleasure
of speaking with that I feel like really
represent what was happening at the time
but also more importantly they had a
stake in the game so these were people
involved in these transitioning times so
this is Louisa white she created her
blog in 2005 it's called the Wednesday
shop and she was super concerned when
she started making her her blog that she
was late to the game there already 20
other food blogs on the internet and but
she's just now obviously she's
considered to be one of the first week
bloggers and so I asked her like how was
blogging food blogging's changed over
the past twelve years and she said when
I started there were some unspoken rules
I think still apply early on people
would come to blogs to be a part of the
community leave thoughtful comments make
friends and that's how you would build
really readership link back don't steal
recipes without attribution those rules
still apply but because people now read
on their phones people don't comment as
much I think that's why Instagram has an
enormous success because you can like a
post and you can also comment but you'll
notice there's always more like than
comments these blocks don't give you
that option you'll notice that my
clothes from five years ago got far more
comments than they do now even though my
readership hasn't dropped so back in the
early days of internet blogs the bodies
acted more of a space for unique
communities to develop and people in
terms of food blog typically women to
share their stories people felt
empowered to share that the tales of
their successes and failures our recipes
came to them
and anecdotes that they did necessarily
get a space to tell and explain in other
ways for example I just had a kid and
the child won't eat any of the food I'm
cooking and it's really picky how do i
how do i cook something and this is kind
of similar maybe to write the writing
questions and early food in women's
magazines but this was a lot more
dynamic and had a lot more people able
to participate and so this also this
kind of sense that things are changing
with online discourse happened in the
restaurant industry so these are some
images from the 1999 to 2000 issues of
food arts magazine which is the first
Western in food industry magazine that
the mountain is 1319 eating army and
just like everybody everywhere ever was
worried about the y2k bug and what did
this mean for the future and the
internet so was the restaurant industry
so here are just some some drawings I
really loved from some issues like I'd
love the shaft talking on his cell phone
and it's like this hotline to technology
frontiers and power sucks gonna deal
with this people were worried that now
there were two people we're gonna read
the cool we're gonna just want to watch
stuff on the computer and not go to
restaurants there's a big problem well
not problem but problem for the people
that owned restaurants Pia's a lot of
waiters started these forums where they
would communicate about poor working
conditions bad like bad things that
we're happening within the industry and
so rather than it just taking place in
like a background like this is a problem
now this could be publicized online and
then there was also this issue of like
oh crap now we need to market ourselves
online
we make a restaurant digital this seems
like an oxymoron to a lot of people and
then it's my I have one more oh I have
one more because I wanted to share so
quickly oh yeah so I love this one the
people eating on a floppy disk with the
long printout of reservations and things
going and you know the way yours having
to move fast so there was a lot of
discussions of like how is this going to
change the dynamics of us eating in
restaurants so now we're at the late
2000s early 2010's and this was really a
turning point for food techs in their
infrastructure so coincidentally there
was the economic downturn the recession
in 2008 that there was a little bit of
the fire but it's sort of it wasn't the
only thing that was happening that was
crippling the food media industry at
least as people I know and I didn't
print for a long time in 2010 was the
first time that point and shoot camera
sales declined as smartphones overtook
them so that was kind of like a
watershed moment and the internet and
social media had become a lot more
active so it's not just the economic
troubles that were hitting restaurants
but also but also just that people were
going to other media and so Ruth Michael
was the final editor of Gourmet magazine
before coltd in 2009 and she had
something really positive to say
actually in the wake of her magazine
being shut down like how the Internet's
good for food culture and she said the
formal is simple when you cook for
people they feel cared for that hasn't
changed what's different is that 40
years ago my interest in food felt up
like a very solitary passion today
everybody's interested in cooking and
cooked connect in ways we didn't dream a
big of before computers in our life now
thanks to Twitter I have friends
never met all around the world these
friendships may be virtual but to me
they are real I am no longer alone when
I cook in my kitchen but then on the
other side we have Christopher Kimball
was sort of infamous in the food
industry for many reasons but he's
behind cooks illustrated in America's
Test Kitchen and he wrote an obituary to
Gourmet magazine when it shuttered in
the New York Times and he said the
shuttering of gourmet reminds us that in
a clicker diet advertising marketplace
one ruled by a million instant pundits
we're anonymous Twitter comment might be
seen to pack more resonance and useful
content than an article that reflects a
lifetime of experience experts are not
created from the top down but from the
bottom up they can no longer be
coronated their voices have been deemed
essential to the lives of their
customers that leaves I think little
room for thoughtful considerate
editorial content so then looking kind
of a little bit more about how
restaurants dealt with this the consumer
is creating warm food content as well
with the header front of house at mock
Mugaritz
which is a two Michelin star restaurant
in Basque Country in the top ten world's
best restaurants and he's been there for
over ten years since the inception of
this restaurant and so it was really
interesting to hear and describe how in
2005 they had one person who would look
over the social media content for the
whole restaurant and if they saw that
somebody was tweeting from the table
everybody in the front of house would
rush down make sure that person had you
know good lady and had the right
information you know make sure that if
they were going to post it on
it was going to be good and accurate
they did this for a few more years but
then you know like once it became
commonplace and he actually marked 2010
which like I said was that year that
that the camera phones surpassed Queen
and shoot cameras as the kind of the
year when it became normalized and so
after that they kind of just ignored
everybody taking photos and he says that
now everyone takes photos it does not
matter age ethnicity anything it's
everyone and when they set a table they
have to figure out where on the table
people are going to be able to put their
phones down if you think will and like I
said this is a too much lip store
restaurant and these are conversations
that the top of the top is having so now
kind of looking at the the consumer side
of the content creators so these are two
different restaurants so on this side we
have this place called broken coconuts
and on this side is Chacho macho and NER
like very trendy places in Manhattan and
it looked almost like that - cool POS
right now when people are designing
restaurants one thing that a lot of them
are considering and there's a lot of
articles within the industry out about
this is like how do you make your
restaurant Instagram a bowl like what is
your visual hook and you can see through
this that like neon pink neon sign
reading work really well the branding of
food is really important so I know
you're also probably wondering like are
we living in a simulation and all this
kind of looks the same it doesn't really
matter but it is kind of weird and we're
kind of also now that have this
proliferation of designer created
content but like who controls the
narrative around food now that is the
type of food related media draws out
perfectly drowns out professionally
created content so instead of seeing
what the chef wants you to see you're
seeing what the person who's eating is
transit so the sort of what the chef's
food and then so 2016 bone Appetit
magazine did a culture issue that I was
super excited for and then really
disappointed so in this in this side in
this magazine made pretty much pointed
out here all these trends that are
happening like on social media like how
to blow up your newsfeed how did we get
off food obsessed but they never really
talked about like why is this happening
which is what I view is kind of my
research but also more more interesting
about this there's a weird trend of
explicit delays of food text creation
process that keeps on popping up all
over Instagram and even on the cover of
this food magazine so users keep on
posting photos as someone taking photos
of food it is an intrinsically meta
practice if you think about it in
particular it demonstrates the awareness
of the production component of everyday
user-generated food text but also it
embraces the lens of mediation the
camera phone has introduced into the
dynamic of the meal experience
and then I also spoke with David mom
who's a major food artist creative
director and an influencer and and he
said like food media today is pretty
much all the same like there are five
trends that you can pretty much tag to
every single food image you see on
Instagram there to the shooting food
from the overhead perspective there's
listing ramen or noodles high into the
air for the photo there's like the
doughnut Aaron have to show the insides
there's the sped up videos of you know
bird's-eye view down of the food being
made and then cheese poles are super
notorious as well but then so if if
there's kind of this homogenous
overwhelming world happening of food tux
creation like what two chefs do now so
this is renews FPE from nova india it's
probably my favorite Instagram so he was
a lot of content of him foraging through
the Nordic fields looking for a
restaurant ingredients going all over
the world crustaceans food that showing
videos of meals that they try to create
that think go well so he's kind of
trying to reclaim this narrative of this
is my food that I'm creating it's not
just your Instagram picture and it's
really giving this ability to also the
chef process that happens and this is
it's important to note that like the
dynamics of a successful chef in fine
dining is cultural and symbolic capital
versus economic like straight-up
economic cash money so that's kind of
where fine-dining media production is
different than middle middle middle
chain
then one more one more people I want to
work with people I want to bring up so
this is a Lewis and Jordan broke of El
Celler de can Roca so this is it's been
like top three restaurants in the world
and he's considered the best pastry chef
in the world and so when one's asked
about social media food they said what's
different now is everybody will come to
your restaurant and know exactly what
their food will look like so you have to
think of other ways to innovate that
dining experience in ways that a photo
cannot capture but on the flip side
since everybody is seeing the images
coming from your restaurant
you have more space to tell a narrative
outside of your restaurant so so he was
talking about how he created a dish that
was based off of smelling his nieces
head when she was just born then
sweetness and it was kind of milky and
he created a dish after this typically
the chef would not be able to tell this
story he would just present the dish and
he would know that story but now through
Instagram you can show photos of the
process and be able to tell that story
to a much larger audience and also think
he said that the the chef community has
been able to become much bigger and
global because he's able to connect and
share his working process with other
chefs too so kind of putting it all
together I wanted to do like a quick
game I'd only
one minute but like a game of contrasts
to show like how the department
functions have shifted so that reverses
yep
both of these are so exactly how many
people are familiar with Zagat yeah do
you know that it started with a bunch of
people's mailing out food surveys and
then a married couple aggregating them
and then reading the reports and so it's
actually couldn't not that different to
Yelp except that Yelp is a lot more
impersonal and this is my experience at
a specific restaurant so those from the
group knowledge coming together to group
knowledge coming together but then
fragment size and I'm gonna have to skip
through my game and unfortunately I
think to go to so in conclusion you can
ask more about that in the questions
so in conclusion while the underlying
purpose of a construction of yeah so
while the underlying purpose of the
construction and consumption of food
techs remains the same authority of food
culture and its resulting narrative
control has shifted due to the
convergence of who text and digital
media affordances so that means that
listening to mainstream culture and
becoming embedded in that or we're
trying to make changes from the top down
is the way to go in terms of thinking
about how you you get into the scenario
so right now award went granting bodies
like Michelin Guide or world's best 50
restaurants do you have a lot of sway
over what findings that what fine dining
institutions are accepted as such
however the Netflix of the fact of being
profiles on chef's table and are the
popularity of a restaurant on Instagram
and tags and check-ins is also a very
real legitimizing course that is
directly in monetary
the impacting the industry so in the end
going back to my original problem like
if we want to produce new food
interventions we need to figure out how
to make them fit within the stories and
culture as we live in it right now we're
seeing very individualized narratives
emerging about people showing who they
are through their choices and food and
what they display and so I think I have
some things that's with them but I'm
gonna skip it okay well instead of
asking what does the future food look
like I think we should be asking what
does the future food culture talk about
what the role of class and race might
play in the research I was really struck
watching a chef's table that this was
for an extremely highbrow audience of
people who really have no concerns about
access to food or about hunger issues
and so on it struck me as a very kind of
alienating experience and very much
about plating and design and funny
for very large amounts of money and that
was that thought with Rocco Mediate
towards the end when you talked about
the description of a food smelling
nothing to do with the reality and you
know the flip side from that where main
culture you know all Yelp is people are
actually talking about like I wouldn't
pay his cheeseburger they haven't worth
five dollars and you know so that
element I would be out there but it
feels like separated from being a poor
maid yes I think you you hit on a lot of
points there some of them being like
worries about access to food another in
terms of also being part of food culture
you are hitting on like just focusing on
design and not worrying about the
implications maybe for that and then the
last one you can repeatedly said why
they going to this sort of practical
reality of a part of food culture which
is people give out reviews to tell you
if it's worth your money to get out of a
place to eat out versus the gourmet food
culture that is about visual visual
presentation and the image of the
substitute for actually eating yeah so I
have a few things to say on that one
it's what's been really interesting is
now that these mine dining chefs have
been able to get a lot more publicity
through things like Instagram a lot of
them have started doing food
accessibility and food security work
through having this greater voice so for
example Massimo burrata
Bharathi I was
like burrata like the cheese but he
right now is considered the best chef in
the world and in Paris he just opened a
homeless a homeless restaurant so only
homeless people are allowed to eat there
and it creates really fantastic food for
them we also started seeing this trend
where Michelin star chefs will create
more accessible price-point versions of
their meal so for example Jordi Roca the
pastry chef he has an ice cream place in
downtown Barcelona where you can get ice
cream for two euros that's that's
inspired by a dessert that you can get
at El Celler de can Roca so they're kind
of trying to think about like how do I
take my vision and make it more
accessible I think it also has to do
with like building a greater cultural
capital for them this economically
motivated but also like you have Dan
barbers which does a lot of food
security issues there's a bunch of chefs
in San Francisco that are really working
to try to bring fresh food and working
with local chefs in underserved areas to
to get more leg there there are efforts
and they are the chefs are trying to
give it that kind of still of glamorize
food culture narrative so that people
pay attention and help but they're not
always successful because they are an
outsider is kind of coming in for the
most part but also a lot of chefs are
are not coming from much it's a very
anti elitist culture if anything I know
that is comes off as very elite but
these are a lot of people that failed
out of high school didn't go to college
nothing else works so I started working
in kitchens so you can't discount like
their experiences and think this is this
is only like 40 20 because the people in
the kitchens typically aren't I don't
know if that answers all of your
questions but I
for another few hours yeah I honestly
don't know too much about Food Network
because except for what I watched from
it that seems to be very formulaic in
terms of they know that these things get
high ratings so they just keep on
rebranding them and it's like now it's
Cupcake Wars and now it's kids cooking
and things like that but though the Food
Network chefs typically do not have this
nature process-oriented Instagram
presence the way fine dining shops do
also critical
rhetoric
yeah
restaurant industry
notice over the last 10 years or so
across the chain of production
inspiration deserving
but at least not showed up
yeah so I think especially through the
chat since appearences they're able to
show where the ingredients come from
those farmers are now becoming part of
this narrative and maybe if you went to
approve your restaurant and they put a
plate down you wouldn't know where that
came from maybe they would tell you it
came from a farm but now you can look on
the chef's Instagram and actually see
like the pigs coming out with the chef
and their chef being like you're the one
I'm going to take yeah yeah no but but
that's something that is very common I
think it's kind of twofold one it's to
justify the high prices these chefs are
not making a killing the fact of the
matter is a lot of them raising very
high quality ingredients and supporting
local farmers and that does not come
cheap especially in as such an
industrialized food system that we live
in now so I think part of their motives
of showing this behind the scenes these
are the ingredients this is the woman
that made this hand by Chee this cheese
by hand for three months but now you're
gonna eat it's like this is why you're
your meal is gonna cost $200 but also I
think it is helping and you don't just
see fine-dining chefs posting but I like
in Boston a lot of the people in
kitchens are posting photos of them
creating food and I think in having more
visibility of that behind the house
process is helping people within society
you become well I think they should have
already been okay with raising wages for
kitchen workers but maybe now when
there's the three-percent kitchen staff
you know price at the end of your meal
it's like oh well I see them clothes on
Instagram like they're doing work this
is something they care about it's kind
of giving visibility
the labor as well okay great so kind of
going to this tech of the solution for
everything thank you so I want to first
of all say Soylent is just the male
version of slimfast and he came to the
market later so I'm not too impressed on
that print but also when it was my my
notes on it sorry but also when it when
it got first introduced to the market it
was sold on the issues of productivity
convenience health sustainability but
then if you're reading the reviews of
people on like vice that we're saying I
ate only Soylent for 30 days and this is
how I felt it is that people had social
isolation because food is such a huge
part of community creation and our
identity and boredom and like identity
crises and it's just like a whole bunch
of unintended consequences so pretty
pretty much they're trying to isolate
themselves from food culture in a way
and if now I feel it the way that
silence marketing and product changes
are going now there's a chive version of
Solon so like if we're starting to
flavor all of it it's not just this like
utilitarian thing anymore and the spices
are the most politically wrong area ever
and now it's like oh look it's like an
ice cream but it's Soylent um so I think
they're kind of catching on to what I'm
saying is that you can't just have these
technological interventions and expect
them to catch on I also agree especially
with your earlier point that it's not
just technological innovation that needs
happened it's a lot of food waste there
are so many things
much much better but it's just a matter
of changing the narrative and getting
people to buy into it and really being
committed to making these changes
[Applause]